what's the best lie you've ever told an  uber driver before so when i was in  college i went out with a group of my  friends and that night coincidentally i  was the only one who wore white and they  all wore black so we went around saying  it was my bachelorette party and i  remember telling the uber driver about  my fiance we've been dating two years  his name is jeff he was a computer  software engineer and he proposed to me  romantically by the ocean at sunset in  florida crazy thing is i don't even have  a ring on but we got free drinks all  night i didn't get carted at the bar and  i learned that guys do not care if  you're engaged about to be married  they will still hit on you